- Welcome back.
How is it the end of our show already?
I'd love to use our last
few moments together
to answer some of your questions.
First up, social media
questions were on fire today.
Don asking a tough one via
Twitter, "Waffles or pancakes?"
Neither, sausages.
Hello, virtual friends.
Who has a question? Christina?
- Yes. Hi.
- How are you?
- Good. I love you so much.
- I love you too, Christina.
Do you have a question?
- I do.
I know that you just seem so fearless,
and I just want to know
what your biggest fear is.
- Oh, Christina, my god,
that's a good question.
I'm afraid of anything bad
happening to the people I love.
That's probably a common fear.
It's straight to the
protection, the ones I love.
Other than that, I say in life,
you got to go for it and be fearless.
Love the ones you love, but go for it,
and never forget to make the
most of every single day.
(upbeat music)